and check this out Training Day in the
rain Metro posting this on Facebook just
a few hours ago officers are motor
school learning how to properly pick up
an 800 pound bike
in the rain and as you can see the rain
was only making things much more
difficult yeah that's what you have to
do you actually have to use your legs
100 800 pounds because they're carrying
all that gear but in the rain it's
making it even more difficult for this
fellas that's a real life scenario right
there yes that's a it's a functional
actor right because you're going to be
in that situation and they have to hurry
up you know you got to make sure you
will hurry up you look at the video 10
minutes ago we showed with the Metro
officer saving a guy's life who was in
the DUI crash literally pulled out of
fire so it's in those moments they
practice it now though so much respect
for you guys great job there